cette semaine à paroles autochtone
quelle est la meilleure chanson pour
parler de décolonisation et de
réconciliation oui bienvenue par heure
tokten si ces milices au moulin du puits
alors cette semaine je vais répondre à
la question de filer avec une seule
réponse mais vraiment avec quatre
réponses je suis désolé philipp c'est
très difficile de pouvoir répondre à une
chanson de réconciliation et de
décolonisation en même temps donc je
vais te donner mais mon top 4 des
chansons que je pense dans un processus
historique pour moi représente la
décolonisation vers la réconciliation
première chanson c'est une à nous de
kashtin sorti en 1989 c'était une des
premières fois où j'entendais des
chansons dans ma langue à moi qui ai
linou emon apparaître dans les grands
médias soit la télé ou à la radio donc
pour moi décoloniser ça veut dire aussi
se dire qu'on a le droit d'exister dans
les médias tout de suite après je
donnerais buffy sainte-marie est due
pour dire de la discographie entière de
l'officiel n'at il pas ce qu'elle a
toujours fait de la musique par rapport
au droit d'exister de sortir de montrer
comment on est fort comme peuple comme
nations les peuples autochtones donc je
donne la discographie de boeuf saipem et
particulièrement que la chanson est donc
non moi je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
vraiment un faible pour celle qui parle
justement de décolonisation et de fierté
d'exister en tant que premier peuple
ensuite c'est une chanson de tribe cored
et ses bannières bridge to the ground
et c'est pour parler quand même que
quand on veut parler de réconciliation
et de décolonisation il faut accepter
l'histoire qui est malheureusement tu
risques existent entre nous et par
l'humour en utilisant une partie du film
de la famille adams ou mercredi à dun
s'est déguisé en pocahontas mais ne pas
40 ans qui refuse d'aller manger ou
souper de la fin du giving saleh a amené
beaucoup d'humour dont nous on ne veut
plus se faire dire que c'était une
histoire d'amitié mais que ça a vraiment
été une colonisation qui nous a été fait
et cette musique là et quand même
apprécié par autochtones et non
autochtones dans le même temps et pour
finir quand on veut aller vers la
réconciliation c'est à dire travailler
ensemble s'écouter accès
des l'histoire qu'on a vécu en commun
j'irai avec l'album ni comme hamilton
qui tenait bon avec des jeunes
autochtones et non autochtones qui
chantent ensemble et toutes les chansons
dans cet album là je les trouve
extraordinaire donc j'ai pas pu en
choisir une
mais je te recommande de l'écouté
d'ailleurs si vous avez des chansons de
décolonisation des chansons de
réconciliation vous pouvez les mettre
dans les commentaires n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo d'ailleurs pour
qu'on puisse en avoir plus de sélection
de chansons et c'était pas à nous
envoyer vos questions à paroles
autochtone je souhaite une belle semaine